in this video we will study about the
compliment system we will talk about the
overview the various activation Pathways
involved and the various immune effects
of the compliment system before
beginning make sure to subscribe Us on
YouTube for all the upcoming videos and
also make sure to like our page on
Facebook for all the flash cards and
interesting stuff links are in the
description
below the compliment system is a group
of about 20 plasma proteins that form
essential part in the innate immunity
the word compliment is used because the
complement system enhances or complement
our
immunity the complement system proteins
are mainly synthesized in the liver and
then widely distributed among the body
tissues and the fluids the complement
system comes into effect only when it is
activated out of the 20 plasma proteins
of the compliment system 11 proteins are
mostly involved named as B C1 to C9 and
D these are mainly enzyme precursor and
they catalyze a series of entic
reactions that form the final products
of the compliment system that have
various immune
effects now let's look at how the
compliment system is activated the first
is the complement activation resulting
due to the antibody antigen reaction
which is known as the classical
pathway the second is through the
bacterial endotoxin which is known as
the alternative pathway and the third is
the lectin pathway that results due to
the protein known as menos binding
lectin now let's study in a bit detail
about the classical pathway
the main trigger of the classical
pathway is the interaction between the
antibodies and antigen this reaction
activates the C1 component of the
complement system the C1 component then
Cleaves C4 component into a smaller
component c4a and a larger component c4b
the C1 combines with c4b and forms
c14b this is an enzyme which converts C2
into a c2a and
c2b these two components combine and
form the c14 B2
a this is an enzyme known as the C3
convertase the C3 convertase then splits
C3 into c3a and
c3b the c3b combines with the C3 convert
and forms
c14b 2 a
3B this is also an enzyme known as the
C5
convertase the C5 convert similarly
converts C5 into
c5a and c5b out of which c5b is the
larger product and combines with C6 7 8
and
9 to form c5b
6789 which is the membrane attack
complex in this Cascade you can see some
components like c5a and c3a which do not
have any use they have other immune
effects which we will discuss later
now let's talk about the alternative
pathway of the activation of the
complement system as we all just studied
the antibody antigen reaction is the
main trigger for the activation of the
classical pathway but the alternative
pathway is mainly triggered by the
bacterial endotoxin the bacterial
endotoxin is a lipopolysaccharide
compound which is found in the outer
membrane of the gr negative bacteria the
other triggers of the alternative
pathway are the yeast cell and the Cobra
Venum
Factor the first step is the spontaneous
hydrolysis of Factor C3 which is present
in a blood plasma this hydrolysis is a
spontaneous process where the factor C3
is converted to factor
c3b this allows the attachment of the
factor B to the factor c3b and opens the
active site on Factor B the factor D
which is another complement enzyme then
splits Factor B into subcomponents
Factor ba a and Factor BB the factor BB
then combines with
c3b and forms the C3 convert of the
alternative pathway this may have a
different complement structure but has
similar function of converting C3 into
subcomponents C3 a and c3b the rest of
the steps are similar to that of the
classical pathway that is the formation
of C5 convert a and subsequently the
formation of membrane attack complex
which has a complement formula c5b 6789
now let's talk about the lectin Manos
pathway for the activation of the
compliment system the lectin Manos
pathway depends upon the protein known
as Manos binding lectin or the MB L
which is synthesized in the liver
organisms like neria Canada and
salmonella have glucose and Manos
residues in their cell wall whenever
these organisms enter the human body the
protein Manos binding lectin recognizes
this and activates a proteas called the
masp or the Manos binding lectin
Associated Serene proteas the masp is a
proteas which binds Manos binding lectin
the masp then triggers the activation of
components C4 and C2 into their sub
components C4 a and c4b and similarly C2
into C2 a and
c2b the factors c4b and c2a combined to
form the C3 convertase of the lectin
pathway this C3 convertase has a similar
function as described earlier and then
the pathway proceeds further as
described earlier now let's talk about
the immun effects of the various
complement products the first is the
opsonization the factor c3b strongly
activates the neutrophils and macrofagos
these activated neutrophils and
microphases then engulf the foreign
microorganisms known as
phagocytosis the second immune effect is
the cell
Lis the membrane attack complex the c5v
6789 has a effect of rupture of the
bacterial cell wall which destroys large
amount of bacterial load the third
effect is chemotaxis where Factor c5a
attracts the neutrophils and macrophases
to the area where the antigen is
present another compliment effect is the
activation of the mass cells the factors
c3a c4a and c5a have a direct effect of
activation of the mass cells and the
basophils this causes the release of
large amount of mediators of
inflammation like histamine and
serotonin which potentiate the immune
response so this was all about the comp
event pathway thank you so much for
watching this video make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
continual support stay tuned for the
upcoming videos on medsimplified